what is it like to travel with Justin we
would go to Oktoberfest in Germany
people were like that guy looks like
Justin Bieber there's no chance like
people were so shocked that like people
just didn't really think it was him no
mask no sunglasses actually I think
there's a video online you see a guy
actually tried to start a fight with
Justin out of nowhere and I went and I
just [__] took the guy down yeah when
you walk around without security no
security isn't that dangerous for him
sometimes he just wants to do normal
things you know there were times my mom
would call me she's like where are you
at I was like oh why it's like Justin's
here if you want to come over we just
ordered pizza he would just like go to
my parents house randomly and order
pizza and hang out with my parents and
watch TV like he just loves normal
things